This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。欢迎收听我的播客《2%》。在这个充满现代奇观的奇异世界里，我将剖析精神坚韧、体能锻炼以及建立心理韧性的种种迹象。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你终将破茧成蝶，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。即数字“2”加上英文的percent，可在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台上收听。欢迎收听《回首往事》播客。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是个重要的时刻。1984年对我来说也意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J，我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的嘉宾包括朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜爱的作家。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代那样。1984年是个疯狂的年份。那确实是个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，再也没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台上收听《回首往事》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你喜爱的治疗师兼主持人克尔·加姆斯为您带来的《艰难一课》。这个空间旨在探讨黑人男性的经历，进行真诚的对话——这些对话在其他地方谈论实在不够安全，但在这里，你是在和一个深谙此道的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人背负着一副重甲？它向世界释放出的信号是：你可不是好惹的。然而，仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台上收听《艰难一课》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。埃伦女士，你曾两次伪造这份特定的检测报告，对吗？我伪造过一次检测报告。互联网上的一群侦探花费了一番功夫，才揭开了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个男人也遭遇了同样的经历。格雷格，一个女同性恋。
Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology.
迈克尔·兰吉尼。我简直大开眼界。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这里是《陷入爱网》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于承担了后果。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台上收听《陷入爱网》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们将探讨20多岁时经历的一些重大生活改变和转折，以及它们对我们心理的意义。
Hello everybody, welcome back to the show. Welcome back to another episode. It is so great to have you here. So great to have you here for another discussion, new listeners, old listeners. It is a really interesting topic this week. I'm so excited about it. I'm also a little bit nervous. This topic took me so long to write and a lot of thinking time, I think, because it's one that I think personally influenced. and impacts every single person in their 20s, every single person in their teenage years, in their 30s, almost at every stage of life. And it is so complex. So this week, we are going to discuss the psychology of diet culture and how we can embrace our bodies in whatever form they come, despite excessive societal pressure to kind of conform to a particular beauty standard and a particular body type. There is so much content to cover. I'm really excited to explore some of the findings and intricacies around this topic. I think as our
大家好，欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到新的一期节目。很高兴能邀请到大家。非常高兴能和新老听众朋友们一起探讨另一个话题。本周的主题非常有趣。我对此感到非常兴奋。同时我也稍微有点紧张。这个话题花了我很长时间来构思，也经历了很多思考，我想，是因为它深刻地影响着每一个处于20多岁、十几岁甚至30多岁的人，几乎涵盖了人生的每一个阶段。而且它是如此复杂。所以本周，我们将探讨饮食文化的心理学，以及如何在社会要求我们顺从某种特定审美标准和体型的巨大压力下，以任何形态接纳我们的身体。有太多内容需要讨论了。我非常高兴能探索围绕这个话题的一些研究发现和错综复杂的细节。我认为，随着我们的
society has become more self-aware of the dangerous impacts of social media and general popular media on how we see our bodies, discussions on the harms of diet culture have become so much more prevalent. And that is such a brilliant, brilliant thing because I think I really don't think I can name even a single person in my life who has not been influenced in some way by the standards set by our society and a society that is inherently impacted and inherently caters to diet culture in some way or another. I know personally this topic and, you know, diet culture has impacted me throughout my adolescence, throughout my 20s so far, in a way that has been really insidious and has been sometimes hard to shake. So I think that is why I'm super excited to talk about
社会越来越意识到社交媒体和大众传媒对我们如何看待自己身体的危险影响，关于饮食文化危害的讨论也变得越来越普遍。这是一件非常、非常棒的事情，因为我认为，我真的说不出我生命中有哪怕一个人没有受到社会标准以及某种程度上固有影响、迎合饮食文化的社会的某种影响。我知道就我个人而言，这个话题，还有饮食文化，在我的青春期以及至今的20多岁里，一直以一种非常隐蔽且有时难以摆脱的方式影响着我。所以我想这就是为什么我超级兴奋来谈论
it and also to kind of shed a light on some of the consequences that we don't always know that can be incredibly severe over our mental well-being and our physical health. In particular, we are going to talk about basically the psychology behind diet culture is. so influential, how it takes form, how it impacts us to treat our bodies in a certain way, especially in this decade of our 20s. We're going to talk about the impact that it has on us from an early age. We're going to talk about social approval, the impact on self-esteem, body dysmorphia and mental health, amongst other things. But before we begin this episode and get into some of the content, I would just like to give a brief disclaimer. This
这个话题，同时也为了揭示一些我们未必了解、但可能对我们的心理健康和身体健康造成极其严重后果的影响。特别是，我们将探讨饮食文化背后的心理学为何如此具有影响力，它是如何形成的，以及它如何影响我们以某种特定方式对待自己的身体，尤其是在我们20多岁的这个十年里。我们还将探讨它从小对我们产生的影响，以及它对社会认同、自尊、身体变形恐惧症和心理健康等方面的影响。但在我们开始这期节目并进入部分内容之前，我只想做一个简短的免责声明。本
episode will include discussions and descriptions of disordered eating and diet culture. So if this is something that is particularly triggering for you, I would just ask that you do a quick mental health check, a quick check of your emotional state at the moment, and ask yourself whether this is something you need to listen to today. I promise the episode will still be here in a week, two weeks, a month's time, so you can always come back to it when you feel more prepared but if this is something that is going to trigger you, maybe just sit this one out for a little while. If anything in this episode is distressing, there are contact numbers in the description for someone you can speak to if you need help and if you need clinical assistance. I also just want
期节目将包含对饮食失调和饮食文化的讨论与描述。因此，如果这个话题特别容易勾起你的痛苦回忆，我请求你先快速做一下心理健康检查，评估一下自己当下的情绪状态，并问问自己今天是否真的需要听这期节目。我向你保证，这期节目一周后、两周后、一个月后依然会在这里，所以当你感觉准备更充分时，随时可以回来听。但如果这个话题会触动你，也许你可以暂时跳过这期节目。如果本期节目中的任何内容让你感到痛苦，节目简介中提供了一些联系电话，如果你需要帮助或临床援助，可以拨打这些电话。我同时只想
to state we cannot talk about everything today. We are going to do a whole other episode primarily on eating disorders and the impact on us in our 20s. And like I said, is a topic I feel really, really deeply about. It's definitely something that has personally impacted me amongst many, many of my friends, many, many of you guys as well, I'm sure. So I'm excited to kind of dispel some of the ambiguity and the confusion around why we often buy into diet culture, even when we don't really want to. And we're going to discuss some of the harms, but importantly the psychology behind how we can push back against diet culture and embrace our bodies despite this pressure to kind of cater towards societal expectations about how we should look.
说明，我们今天无法涵盖所有内容。我们接下来会专门制作另一期节目，主要探讨饮食失调及其对我们20多岁人群的影响。正如我所说，这是一个我感触极深的话题。这绝对是一个对我个人以及我的许多朋友、我相信还有你们当中许多人产生过影响的话题。所以我很高兴能消除一些关于“为什么我们常常会接受饮食文化，即使我们内心并不真正想要这样”的模糊感和困惑。我们将讨论其中的一些危害，但更重要的是探讨背后的心理学：我们如何才能抵制饮食文化，并在关于我们应该长成什么样子的社会期望压力下，依然接纳我们的身体。
So let us get into it. Let us begin the discussion. I'm so excited. Thank you again for joining us. Let's go. So essentially diet culture, it refers to a rigid, of cultural and social expectations, alongside ingrained systems and ingrained beliefs and behaviours that convince us to value a certain physique or type of body, one that we deem physical
那么让我们切入正题。让我们开始讨论吧。我太兴奋了。再次感谢大家的加入。我们开始吧。从本质上讲，饮食文化指的是一套僵化的文化和社会期望，伴随着根深蒂固的系统、信仰和行为，它们说服我们去重视某种特定的体型或身材——即我们认为在生理上
attractive, physically attractive, often that's one that is thin over our physical health and emotional well-being. Diet culture, it's essentially rooted in fat phobia, but it's often disguised as health and wellness as something that's trying to make us better people and treat our body's role. I think it's an overgeneralization to say that the word diet is probably, you know, ultimately problematic, but it's a fact that the vast diet industry, it essentially benefits from our insecurity and our fear of being perceived as overweight or as fat. I think it's important to stay here that just because you are a naturally petite, person, or you're thin, doesn't mean you have to feel any shame at all that your body happens to conform
具有吸引力、通常是苗条的身材——将其置于我们的身体健康和情感福祉之上。饮食文化从根本上植根于对肥胖的恐惧，但它常常伪装成健康与养生，伪装成一种试图让我们变得更好、更好地对待我们身体的东西。我认为，把“饮食（diet）”这个词一概而论地认为最终是有问题的，这是一种过度概括，但事实是，庞大的饮食行业本质上正是靠我们的不安全感以及对被视为超胖或肥胖的恐惧来获利的。我认为在这里有必要说明的是，仅仅因为你天生体型娇小
with beauty standards, nor do I think it really helps anyone by enhancing the attractiveness of people who are bigger by dragging another body shape down. We all come in different forms where we are all beautiful at our core. What we're mainly talking about is how diet culture convinces everyone along that spectrum, that no matter what they look like, they could always be thinner, they could always be doing something more to look better. Diet culture, it often emphasizes good foods and fad diets like fasting or cutting out certain food groups. It wants us to excessively focus on what we eat and how much we weigh through calorie
或身材苗条，并不意味着你必须为自己的身体碰巧符合审美标准而感到任何羞耻，我也不认为通过贬低另一种体型来提升体型较胖之人的吸引力能对任何人有所帮助。我们都有着不同的形态，我们在本质上都是美丽的。我们主要在讨论的是，饮食文化如何说服光谱上的每一个人，无论他们看起来如何，他们都可以更瘦一点，他们总可以做更多的事情来让自己看起来更好。饮食文化通常强调好的食物和风靡一时的饮食法，比如禁食或戒掉某些食物类别。它希望我们通过限制卡路里
restriction and excessive exercise. And it essentially normalizes a self-deprecating attitude and belief towards our bodies that we are not good enough, that we are not valuable enough unless we look a certain way. And normally that is extremely thin. This kind of culture is incredibly toxic. I feel like that goes without saying, right? Like it's incredibly toxic because of its obsessive focus on our physical appearance,
和过度运动，过度关注我们吃什么以及我们的体重。它本质上将一种自我贬低的态度和对身体的信念常态化——即如果我们不长成某种特定样子，我们就是不够好的，是没有足够价值的。而通常情况下，这个标准就是极度苗条。这种文化极其有毒。我觉得这简直不言而喻，对吧？它之所以极其有毒，是因为它对我们的外表有着痴迷般的关注，
particularly our weight or what size we wear. And it can be a massive risk. factor for body dysmorphia, for disordered eating and other mental health issues. I don't want any of us to feel any shame if we've fallen into kind of the trap of believing the lies that diet culture has told us, you know, that if we're thinner, if we take a certain pill or a certain supplement, we'll be happier. This is a 71 billion dollar industry, probably even bigger when you consider all the other industries that feed into it. So it's come up with a lot of creative ways to control us and kind of in the most hidden and
特别是我们的体重或我们穿的尺码。这可能是导致身体变形恐惧症、饮食失调和其他心理健康问题的一个巨大风险因素。我并不希望我们中的任何人因为陷入了饮食文化灌输给我们的谎言的陷阱而感到羞耻，比如“如果我们更瘦，如果我们吃了某种药丸或某种补剂，我们就会更快乐”。这是一个高达710亿美元的行业，如果把所有为其提供养分的其他行业都算上，可能规模还要大得多。因此，它想出了许多极具创意的方法来控制我们，而且往往是以最隐蔽、
nefarious of ways, starting as early as childhood in the shows we watch, the media we absorb the beliefs and comments made by those around us, by our parents. I think essentially diet culture is based on control, the diet industry, is based on control, it's based on profit. And I think the most terrifying aspect of this is the underlying message it promotes that our worth is tied to our physical appearance, not how we treat others, not what we contribute to the world, not the people we love or our intelligence or our creativity, you know, the things that truly matter.
最邪恶的方式。从童年开始，从我们看的节目、我们吸收的媒体、周围人以及父母的言论和信念中就开始了。我认为饮食文化本质上是建立在控制之上的，饮食行业是建立在控制之上的，它是建立在利润之上的。而我认为其中最可怕的方面是它所传达的潜在信息：我们的价值与我们的外表挂钩，而与我们如何对待他人无关，与我们为世界做出了什么贡献无关，与我们所爱的人、我们的智力或创造力无关——也就是那些真正重要的事物无关。
It wants us to view our worth by the shape and the size of our bodies, not what is inside. I know that sounds pretty self-explanatory, right? You know, that's a pretty easy way to see things. You know, diet culture convinces us that our body is our most valuable and most attractive and desirable asset, whereas the other things, the quantity and the quality of our souls and the quality of our hearts doesn't really matter. But one way I really like to frame it to myself when sometimes I find myself slipping into this belief that my body is and how I look is a lot more valuable than other parts of myself is to think about myself on my deathbed. I know this is really morbid, but I always think on my deathbed, are people really going to remember how much I weighed?
它希望我们根据身体的形状和大小来评估自己的价值，而不是看内心。我知道这听起来很不言自明，对吧？这是一种相当容易看清事物的方式。饮食文化说服我们，我们的身体是我们最宝贵、最具吸引力和最渴望的资产，而其他东西，我们灵魂的数量和质量、我们内心的质量，其实并不重要。但每当我发现自己陷入这种信念——即我的身体以及我的外表比我身上的其他部分更有价值——时，我非常喜欢的一种自我调整方式，就是想象自己临终时的样子。我知道这听起来很病态，但我总是在想，在我临终的时候，人们真的会记得我有多重吗？
Or if I was two or three or four kilos skinnier, are they really going to. remember what size of clothes I wear? I don't think so. And I think that it seems in the most important moments like at birth, at death, when we're surrounded by people we love, when we're getting married, when we're overcome with joy, our body is the least important thing about us, as long as it's able to do the things we want it to do and be a safe vessel and a safe home for the attributes, the love, the thoughts, feelings, and values that our bodies contain and that our minds and our hearts contain. But diet culture undermines that belief, right? It undermines that belief. It says these things don't matter. It doesn't matter how great a person you are. If you're not thin,
或者我是比现在轻了两三四公斤，他们真的会记得我穿什么尺码的衣服吗？我不这么认为。我认为在最重要的时刻——比如在出生时、在死亡时、在我们被所爱之人包围时、在我们结婚时、在我们被喜悦淹没时——我们的身体其实是我们身上最不重要的东西，只要它能够做我们想让它做的事，并且能够成为一个安全的容器和安全的家，来承载我们的身体、心灵和情感所包含的那些品质、爱、思想、感觉和价值观。但饮食文化破坏了这种信念，对吧？它破坏了这种信念。它说这些事情并不重要。无论你是一个多么棒的人，如果你不够瘦，
well, then you should be doing better. And it really contributes to a lot of debilitating disorders, like anorexia and bulimia, orthorexia, binge eating disorders. These are really serious conditions, right? They're related to persistent eating behaviors and sometimes restrictive behaviors that negatively impact our health, our emotions, our ability to function. And most eating disorders involve a focus that is very similar to that of diet culture. It's focused on your weight, it's focused on your body shape, on your food intake, and it can lead to really dangerous eating behaviors and often and diet culture and that societal obsession with body image and thinness is a huge contributing factor. Okay, I don't want to spend too much time talking on these because I think it needs a whole,
那么你就应该做得更好。它确实导致了许多令人虚弱的失调症，比如神经性厌食症、神经性贪食症、饮食过度紊乱症、暴饮暴食症。这些都是非常严重的状况，对吧？它们与持续的饮食行为有关，有时还伴随着对健康、情绪、机能发挥产生负面影响的限制性行为。大多数饮食失调都包含一种与饮食文化非常相似的关注点。它关注你的体重，关注你的体型，关注你的食物摄入量，这可能导致非常危险的饮食行为，而饮食文化以及社会对体型和苗条的痴迷往往是巨大的促成因素。好了，我不想花太多时间谈论这些，因为我认为这需要一个完全
whole separate episode and it will get its own separate episode where we can talk more about eating disorders and the way they present and the impacts they have. But today, we're just going to talk about some examples of what diet culture might look like and where we can notice it in our behaviours and the things around us, before we kind of discuss the origins and the psychology behind its existence and its prevalence in almost every facet and area of our lives. I think diet culture is particularly insinious because it's lumped in with this suggestion that optimal, it's kind of lumped in with this suggestion about taking care of ourselves, right?
独立的专题节目，它也会有自己的独立节目，届时我们可以更多地谈论饮食失调及其表现形式和影响。但今天，我们只讨论饮食文化可能是什么样的一些例子，以及我们如何在自己的行为和周围的事物中注意到它，然后再讨论其存在及其在几乎我们生活的方方面面中盛行的起源和背后的心理学。我认为饮食文化尤其阴险，因为它与这种建议混为一谈，即最佳状态，它有点与照顾好我们自己的建议混为一谈，对吧？
Like if you count calories and if you eat well, you must be perceived as healthy. But that's not always the case and it appears so often in the media and so often around us that soon we start to believe that eating a certain way that caring about our weight, caring about what we look like is completely normal. It's ubiquitous. We see it in advertisements, TV, movies at work, at the doctor's office, maybe when you're having conversations with friends and family. and of course the big kind of devil in this situation in social media. Just think about how much social media we absorb every day. They really think about how many hours do you spend on your phone? But perhaps you can't remember particular posts or videos,
就像如果你计算卡路里，如果你吃得好，你一定会被认为是很健康的。但事实并非总是如此，它在媒体中频繁出现，在我们周围也如此常见，以至于我们很快开始相信，以某种特定的方式饮食、关心我们的体重、关心我们看起来是什么样，是完全正常的。它是无处不在的。我们在广告、电视、电影、工作场所、医生办公室里都能看到它，也许当你和朋友家人交谈时，当然还有这种情况下的终极恶魔——社交媒体。想想我们每天吸收多少社交媒体内容吧。真的想想你在手机上花了多少个小时？也许你记不清具体的帖子或视频，
but all of that content that you're seeing on a day-to-day basis is being absorbed and processed subconsciously, somewhere in your brain. And when the content we are exposed to frequently reiterates diet culture, frequently reiterates how we're meant to look a certain way, eat a certain way, be a certain way. Suddenly, it becomes part of our belief systems, even without us noticing. So I was having this conversation with my friend the other day about how much of the content we absorb from social media is actually, you know, just loosely concealed diet culture.
但你在日常生活中看到的所有这些内容，都在潜意识里被你的大脑吸收和处理了。当我们接触到的内容频繁重申饮食文化时，频繁重申我们注定应该看起来像某个样子、以某种方式饮食、成为某种人时，突然之间，它就成了我们信仰体系的一部分，甚至在我们没有察觉的情况下。所以前几天我和朋友聊天时就在谈论，我们从社交媒体吸收的内容中，有多少实际上只是（你知道的）略加掩饰的饮食文化。
There's no way around it. It's essentially, I think it's kind of packaged up to appear something else to appear like it's talking about health. But it's diet culture. And it's the kind that if we saw a celebrity actively promoting or a magazine promoting, we would call it out. And we would say, this is actually really unhealthy. This is promoting eating disorders. But when they're packaged up nicely, when they're seen in our Instagram and our TikTok feeds as these like trendy videos, we often don't notice it as much as we should. you know, I always think about TikTok videos about like what I eat in a day and they display
这是无可奈何的。本质上，我认为它被包装成其他东西的样子，假装它是在谈论健康。但它就是饮食文化。如果我们看到某个名人公开宣传或某本杂志宣传这种内容，我们会大声斥责。我们会说，这其实非常不健康。这是在宣扬饮食失调。但当它们被精美地包装起来，当它们作为这些时髦的视频出现在我们的Instagram和TikTok信息流中时，我们往往没有像应该的那样去注意到它们。你知道，我总是在想那些关于“我一天吃什么”的TikTok视频，它们展示了
calories, trending sounds about being skinnier, the idolization of models like Bella had did and an obsession with what they eat, an overrepresentation and idolization of people who are thin across Instagram and other platforms, so many other examples, you know, celebrity diets, before and afters, fitness trends, weight loss pills, diet pills, weight loss shakes, all of those things. The other one that's really huge and is a really big indicator of how diet culture kind of seeps its way into our mind is edited photos and edited images. I'm sure we've all done this once or twice.
卡路里、关于变得更瘦的流行音乐、对像贝拉·哈迪德这样的名模的偶像化以及对他们吃的东西的痴迷、在Instagram和其他平台上对瘦人的过度代表和偶像化，还有太多其他的例子，比如名人饮食、前后对比、健身潮流、减肥药、减肥奶昔，所有这些东西。另一个真正巨大且能很好说明饮食文化如何渗透进我们大脑的指标，就是被修图的照片和编辑过的图像。我敢肯定我们所有人都曾有一两次这样做过。
I have done this. I've edited images of myself to look better, to look thinner. And I don't think I'm alone in this. There's actually been a study on this exact kind of behavior. And it noted that 70% and over 50% of men, so 70% of women, 50% of men aged 18 or 35, reported editing the images they post on social media pretty regularly. And I think this demonstrates not only how diet culture convinces us that we need to put forward a particular image of ourselves as attractive and as thin,
我也这样做过。我编辑过自己的照片，让自己看起来更好、更瘦。我想我并不是唯一的孤例。实际上有一项关于这种具体行为的研究。它指出，70%的女性和50%以上的男性（即18至35岁的女性中有70%，男性中有50%）表示，他们会相当定期地编辑自己在社交媒体上发布的照片。我认为这不仅证明了饮食文化如何说服我们需要展示一个具有吸引力且苗条的特定自我形象，
but also the large amount of overall dissatisfaction we have. with what we naturally look like, with what we truly look like, to the point where we alter images of ourselves to seem ideal. I think this list of diet culture embedded across social media could go on and on and on. We see it all the time, we see it everywhere. And as people and children are accessing social media earlier and earlier in age, it's no wonder that by the time we kind of reach out, adolescence in our teenage years almost I think it's like six in ten people report some form
同时也证明了我们对自己的自然外表、对我们真正的长相有着大量整体的不满，以至于我们甚至会修改自己的照片来显得完美。我认为这种嵌入社交媒体的饮食文化清单可以没完没了地列下去。我们一直都能看到它，到处都能看到它。随着人们和儿童接触社交媒体的年龄越来越早，难怪当我们进入青春期时，几乎可以说大约有十分之六的人会报告某种形式的
of disordered eating this is why it works and this is why it's so impactful when we see this content enough we begin to normalize it so this is known as the concept of normalization this refers to essentially a social process through which ideals and actions come to be seen as normal through things like ideology and propaganda and repetition, such as that, you know, when we see something enough, maybe across social media, it becomes normal to us. It becomes taken for granted, part of our everyday perception and understanding of what the world is like.
饮食失调。这就是为什么它会起作用，这就是为什么它如此具有影响力。当我们看到足够多的这类内容时，我们开始将其实际归为正常。所以这就是所谓的常态化概念，它本质上指的是一个社会过程，通过意识形态、宣传和重复等事物，理想和行动被视为正常的过程，比如当我们看到某种东西足够多时，也许在整个社交媒体上，它对我们来说就变得正常了。它被视为理所当然，成为我们对世界是怎样的日常感知和理解的一部分。
So let's think about this in terms of diet culture. So essentially, this idea of thinness and needing to treat our bodies a certain way to align with beauty standards and ideals of attractiveness. This becomes an idealized norm through repetition of, you know, images and trends and video content that all promotes the same idea to be thinner as to be better. And this becomes an idealized norm. It's been repeated across our brains enough that we are made to almost obey it or see it as normal in our society. And then there's this way of either rewarding or punishing individuals, often subliminally, for deviating against the ideal. So this is a way that diet culture is able
所以让我们从饮食文化的角度来思考这个问题。本质上，这种苗条的概念以及需要以某种方式对待我们的身体以符合美学标准和吸引力理想的想法。通过不断重复（你知道的）那些宣扬同一个观点的图像、潮流和视频内容，这就成了一种理想化的规范——即变瘦就是变好。这成为了一种理想化的规范。它在我们的脑海中被重复了足够多的次数，以至于我们几乎不得不服从它，或者在我们的社会中视其为正常。然后还有一种奖励或惩罚个人的方式，通常是潜移默化的，针对那些背离这种理想的人。所以这是饮食文化能够
to exert almost maximum control over our behaviours beginning in childhood and in our teenage years. So we have this norm. It's been repeated to us through social media. It's become idealized. and those who match the idealization of thinness and looking a certain way, they are praised. They can fit into traditional clothing sizes they're represented in the media, whilst those who don't meet that ideal, who push back against that norm, are told that they're lazy, they're made to feel uncomfortable, they aren't able to find clothes that fit in traditional stores, they aren't represented, they face bullying particularly online.
对我们的行为施加最大控制的一种方式，从童年和青少年时期就开始了。所以我们有了这个规范。它通过社交媒体向我们不断重复。它已经变得理想化。那些符合苗条和某种特定外表理想化的人会受到赞扬。他们能穿进传统的服装尺码，他们在媒体上有代表性，而那些不符合这一理想、抵制这种规范的人则被告知他们很懒，他们会感到不舒服，他们在传统商店里找不到合身的衣服，他们没有代表性，他们面临霸凌，尤其是在网上。
And so in that way, they're kind of punished and almost forced to fall back in line to cater towards being thinner. This, obviously, I think goes without saying, can cause some pretty long-term issues with our self-perception and our self-worth and the way that we treat our bodies because it promotes this lie. Like I said, your value to society is determined by. how much you fit a particular mould, a particular norm, or a standard of thinness of beauty. And this has inverse, kind of inverse effects as well for people who don't look that way,
因此，通过这种方式，他们受到某种惩罚，几乎被迫重新回归顺从，去迎合变得更瘦的要求。这显然不言而喻，会导致一些关于我们的自我认知、自我价值以及我们对待身体方式的相当长期的持久问题，因为它宣扬了这个谎言。就像我说的，你对社会的价值是由
whereby diet culture has so intensely ingrained in our brains that skinny equals good, skinny equals attractive, skinny equals invaluable, that people who don't meet that socially constructed and manipulated standard experience discrimination in many areas of life and they're told or shamed that they don't have self-control and that they aren't desirable. A thin or fit appearance symbolizes, I think, a lot of important values in our culture. We often confuse it with values like hard work and discipline. So if a person is thin, they're seen as having willpower, they're seen as having self-concure control. These are ideals and values and attributes that we value. Whereas if a person is not
你有多大程度上契合某个特定模具、特定规范或苗条美丽标准所决定的。对于那些长相并非如此的人来说，这也会产生相反的、某种程度上相反的效果，
thin, the assumption is that they must lack self-discipline. They must not have much willpower. And as a result, they experience harmful stigmatization. They're put down. They're harassed. Weight stigma tends to be socially acceptable in diet culture because of that alignment with certain values and certain traits that we want, that we want to achieve, that we want to be like. This has a lot to do with social approval. It's no longer about what you look like. It's no longer about how much you weigh. It's about what your appearance means for your value to society and what your appearance means for how other people see you. And like I said, this has a lot to do with social approval and wanting to be seen as socially valuable and wanting to align with those traits
饮食文化已经将“瘦等于好”、“瘦等于有吸引力”、“瘦等于有价值”深深地烙印在我们的脑海中，以至于那些不符合这种社会构建和操纵标准的人在生活的许多领域都会经历歧视，他们被告知或羞辱说他们缺乏自控力，他们是不受欢迎的。我认为，苗条或健美的外表在我们文化中象征着许多重要的价值观。我们经常把它与努力工作和纪律等价值观混为一谈。因此，如果一个人很瘦，他们就被视为有毅力，被视为有自我控制力。这些是我们珍视的理想、价值观和品质。而如果一个人不
and those moral qualities that are implicitly associated with thinness. The need for social approval, it sustains things like diet culture. Social approval is how we go about being accepted in society and what social standards and expectations we feel like we have to obey. And fitting in with what is a coveted beauty standard, one that is promoted by diet culture of being thin is a way of gaining social approval in so many ways. This internalized belief that if we are thinner, we are happier, people will like us more, people will want to date us, people will admire us, and it all links back to wanting to be accepted
瘦，人们就会想当然地认为他们一定缺乏自律。他们一定没有什么毅力。结果，他们就会遭受有害的污名化。他们被贬低。他们受到骚扰。在饮食文化中，由于体重与我们渴望实现的、我们想要与之相似的某些价值和特质保持一致，体重污名往往在社会上是可以被接受的。这与社会认同有着很大关系。这不再关乎你长什么样。这不再关乎你有多重。这关乎你的外表对于你对社会的价值意味着什么，以及你的外表对于其他人如何看待你意味着什么。就像我说的，这与社会认同以及渴望被视为具有社会价值、渴望与那些
and included as is a natural function of being social beings. I think it's important to understand that diet culture, beyond just eating nourishing foods and taking care of your physical health. And it's often an excuse to engage in the kind of fat phobia that is promoted by diet culture. But instead, I think what it actually does is become quite consuming. Although the facade of diet culture is often marketed as wellness and marketed as fitness and lifestyle friendly, instead it can become all consuming. And it compromises our physical health, our own.
隐性与苗条联系在一起的特质和道德品质保持一致，有着很大关系。对社会认同的需求维持了像饮食文化这样的事物。社会认同是我们融入社会的方式，也是我们觉得必须服从的社会标准和期望。契合饮食文化所倡导的令人艳羡的美丽标准（即苗条），在许多方面都是获得社会认同的一种方式。这种内化信念——即如果我们更瘦，我们就会更快乐，人们会更喜欢我们，人们会想和我们约会，人们会钦佩我们——这一切都追溯到希望被接受和包容的愿望，这是作为社会人的自然功能。我认为重要的是要理解饮食文化，它不仅仅是关于吃营养丰富的食物和照顾你的身体健康。它往往是参与饮食文化所宣扬的那种肥胖恐惧症的借口。但相反，我认为它实际上所做的是变得相当具有消耗性。尽管饮食文化的表象经常被营销为健康、健身和生活方式友好，但它反而会变得让人全神贯注、无法自拔。它损害了我们的身体健康、我们自己的
emotional well-being, and it's not so much promoting sustainable health, really. It's promoting conformity. It's promoting a company. It's promoting an industry that wants to make money off of our insecurity. So let's just talk about some examples of diet culture that we might be able to recognize. One that I noticed in myself, I've noticed in others, I've noticed across social media, is this tendency to label some foods as good and others as bad. So typically that's food like, you know, chocolate and ice cream and burgers, and those are bad foods. Those are bad.
情感福祉，而且它其实并不是在真正促进可持续的健康。它在促进顺从。它在促进一个公司。它在促进一个想要从我们的不安全感中赚钱的行业。那么让我们来谈谈我们可能能够识别的饮食文化的一些例子。我在自己身上注意到、在其他人身上注意到、在整个社交媒体上注意到的其中一个倾向，就是把某些食物贴上“好”的标签，把另一些食物贴上“坏”的标签。通常情况下，那是由巧克力、冰淇淋和汉堡组成的食物，那些是坏食物。那些是坏的。
Whilst things like salad and fruit and juice, those are good foods. Here's the thing that really annoys me about that kind of labeling. Foods don't come with moral labels like good or. bad. Foods are not morally aligned. We don't need to demonize any form of food. It's literally just a cluster of ingredients and nutrients. It's in no way associated with being bad or being evil or needing to be shunned or not consumed. Here's the thing. All foods are good foods. They don't have a moral label. They all have their benefits. Yes, you know, maybe. eating like a chocolate bar every day with every meal.
而沙拉、水果和果汁之类的东西则是好食物。这就是让我对这种标签感到非常恼火的地方。食物并没有附带像“好”或“坏”这样的道德标签。食物在道德上并不是对立的。我们不需要妖魔化任何形式的食物。它字面意思上只是一堆成分和营养物质的组合。它绝不与变坏、邪恶、需要被避开或不被消费联系在一起。事情是这样的。所有食物都是好食物。它们没有道德标签。它们都有各自的好处。是的，（你知道的）也许。每天每顿饭都吃一块巧克力棒。
It's not going to make you feel really great. It's not going to make you feel amazing. That's all right. But it's also great for your happiness to kind of have a yummy treat and feel comfortable eating what you like. And that kind of rhetoric that's pushed by diet culture of some foods being good and some foods being bad is a way for it to kind of control our behaviors and control our habits and our beliefs to cater towards thinness.
这不会让你感觉很好。这不会让你感觉棒极了。这没关系。但偶尔吃点美味的零食并安心吃自己喜欢的东西，对你的幸福感也大有裨益。饮食文化所推崇的这种修辞——即某些食物是好的，某些食物是坏的——是它用来控制我们的行为、控制我们的习惯和信仰以迎合苗条身材的一种方式。
I think linking on from that is the sense of shame that diet culture likes to create in us from eating certain foods that we are told are bad because of their calories or because of some other dietary element. That's another systematic kind of symptom of diet culture, is this societal obsession with calorie intake. I think that's something we can all admit we have done. I certainly have, where you have weighed up two options based on how many calories they have with the specific intention of being aware of your weight.
我认为紧随其后的是一种羞耻感，饮食文化喜欢让我们因为吃了某些我们被告知因为含有卡路里或其他饮食成分而是“坏”的食物而产生这种羞耻感。这是饮食文化系统的另一种症状，即社会对卡路里摄入量的痴迷。我认为这是我们都可以承认自己做过的事情。我当然做过，你会根据卡路里的多少来权衡两个选项，其明确目的就是为了关注自己的体重。
This is especially insidious, I think, when we can so easily access this information on the labels of food or at restaurants or using online apps. this kind of general and prolific display of calorie information, it implicitly tells us that calories are something we should care about, something we should measure, rather than just another property of the foods we eat. Going out to eat, fueling our body, that shouldn't be a mathematical equation. And it also can grossly contribute to excessive calorie counting. There's actually been a lot of research on this that shows that displaying calories on labels and in restaurants, particularly as kind of like an advertising ploy or selling point to make things appear healthier. It actually contributes to that major symptom of diet culture, which is an obsession about how our
我认为这尤其隐蔽，因为我们可以如此轻易地在食品标签上、餐馆里或通过在线应用程序获取这些信息。这种普遍和高产的卡路里信息展示，含蓄地告诉我们卡路里是我们应该关心的东西，是我们应该衡量的东西，而不仅仅是我们所吃食物的另一个属性。外出就餐、为身体补充能量，那不应该是一个数学方程式。而且这也会极大地助长过度计算卡路里的行为。实际上有很多关于这方面的研究表明，在标签上和餐馆里展示卡路里——特别是作为一种广告噱头或卖点，让事情看起来更健康——实际上助长了饮食文化的主要症状，即对我们的
body looks. And along with that, an obsession with food as something to restrict and label rather than enjoy. And from this, food kind of becomes synonymous without physical appearance, and it becomes a tool to manipulate to achieve our dream body or to look thin, rather than it's organic and normal purpose as energy and as fuel for our body. Adding calories to menus and labels on grocery items, all those other things, I think it's actually a really common practice in a lot of cultures and countries these days. I know, Australia where I'm from, they do that at the moment. Friends in the UK have said the same thing. But a professor by the name of Sandeep Renote, I believe, she did all this research into this
外表长相的痴迷。伴随着这一点，对食物的痴迷变成了一种需要限制和贴标签的东西，而不是去享受的东西。由此，食物在某种程度上变得与我们的外表同义，它变成了一种操纵工具，用来实现我们的梦想身材或让自己看起来苗条，而不是回归其作为能量和身体燃料的有机且正常的本能目的。在菜单和杂货商品标签上添加卡路里以及所有这些其他事情，我认为这实际上是当今许多文化和国家中非常普遍的做法。我知道我老家澳大利亚目前就在这么做。我在英国的朋友也说过同样的话。但有一位名叫桑迪普·雷诺特（Sandeep Renote）的教授，我相信，当英国提议做出在菜单上标注卡路里这一改变时，她对所有这些进行了研究。她发现，在菜单上标注卡路里实际上对患有厌食症和贪食症的人来说可能是极具诱发性的，他们可能会（你知道的）寻找低热量的食物。但在另一方面，这可能会导致暴食症患者寻找高热量的食物来触发内疚和羞耻感。她还发现，在这一强制令出台后，与她的病人和客户交谈时，计算卡路里的行为实际上因这一举动而恶化了，对吧？人们更有可能参与其中，因为现在信息对他们来说是触手可及的。它含蓄地告诉他们，这是你应该关心的事情。这是你需要
when the UK was proposing this change to put calories on menus. And she found that placing calories on menus can actually be incredibly triggering for people with anorexia and bulimia who may, you know, search for lower calorie foods. But on the flip, flip side could lead to people with binge eating disorder, finding higher calorie items to trigger guilt and shame. And she also found that talking to her patients and clients after this mandate was put in, that calorie counting is actually worsened by this act, right? People are more likely to engage in it because now the information is available to them. And it implicitly tells them that this is something you should care about. This is something that you need to be.
保持清醒认识的事情，你需要计算卡路里。这会导致如此多的失调症，比如厌食症、正餐饮食失调症、贪食症。这又是饮食文化伪装成对我们有益的事物的一种方式，但它实际上在影响我们的行为和决定，对我们的自我价值、自我认知产生负面影响，并助长了我们之前讨论过的一些失调症。我认为饮食文化还通过许多不同的途径说服我们参与其他活动，这些活动要么限制我们的食物摄入量，要么增加我们的体力活动。那可能是过度运动，为了消耗特定数量的卡路里，或者是为了“赢得”一份零食，为了“赢得”你稍后要吃的一餐。我以前在高中时就会
cognizant of, you need to be counting your calories. And it can contribute to so many disorders, like anorexia, like orthorexia, like bulimia. This is yet another way that diet culture is masked as something that is good for us, but it's really influencing our behaviors and our decisions to negatively impact our self-worth, our self-perception, and contribute to some of those disorders we discussed earlier. I think diet culture also convinces us through many different avenues that we need to take part in other activities that either restrict our food intake or increase our physical activity. That might be excessive exercise to kind of burn off a specific amount of calories or to earn a treat to earn the meal that you're going to eat later. I used to do
这样做。我会想，好吧，我今晚要出去吃晚报，所以我其实不能出去。除非我跑了10公里，否则我不能吃我想吃的食物，因为我必须赢得它。我必须赢得食物。你根本不需要赢得任何东西。食物只是你身体的燃料。仅此而已。还有这种因吃东西而感到内疚或羞耻的感觉，试图用咖啡因或清体茶、尼古丁或水来压制你的食欲，在严重的情况下（你知道的），为了避免吃东西而回避某些社交场合，称体重，然后根据秤上的数字而不是你的感觉来改变你的行为，并且以社交媒体真正帮助我们做到的某种方式崇拜苗条、崇拜减肥。
this when I was in high school. I would be like, well, I'm going out for dinner tonight, so I actually can't go out. I can't eat the foods I want to eat unless I run 10Ks, because I have to earn it. I have to earn food. You don't have to earn anything. Food is just fuel for your body. It's nothing more. There's also this sense of feeling guilt or shame for eating, attempting to suppress your appetite with caffeine or skinny teas, nicotine or water, on the severe end, you know, avoiding certain social situations to avoid eating, weighing yourself and then changing your behaviours based on the number on the scale rather than how you feel and worshiping kind of thinness, worshipping weight loss in a way that social media really kind of helps us do.
它为我们提供了如此多的内容来参与
It provides us with so much content to be able to engage. in this behaviour. And then, of course, there are some of the feelings it creates, some of the impacts that it has on our mental health and our emotional well-being. You know, feeling unworthy or unattractive due to the number on a scale, due to the size of clothes that you wear, feeling unworthy because you don't look like someone else. Assuming that our bodies are responsible for, for good or bad things happening, you know, this idea that no one's going to love me unless I look like some model, you know, if I look like Bella did and assuming that people who do look like that way have it a lot easier. You know, that might be the case, but I also think that
这种行为。然后，当然，还有它产生的一些感觉，它对我们的心理健康和情感福祉产生的一些影响。你知道，因为秤上的数字、因为你穿的衣服尺码而感到毫无价值或没有吸引力，因为你长得不像别人而觉得自己一文不值。假设我们的身体应对发生的好事或坏事负有责任，（你知道的）这种想法：除非我长得像某个模特，否则没有人会爱我（你知道的，如果我长得像贝拉·哈迪德那样），并且假设那些长成那样的人生活要轻松得多。你知道，情况可能确实如此，但我同时也认为
it's a very insidious lie that has been concocted by diet culture to convince us that if we're thin, we'll have everything that we want. You might also find that you feel anxious. around foods and your mood changes based on how you feel about your body that day. And perhaps one of the biggest symptoms of diet culture and the impact it has on our behaviors and our beliefs is body dysmorphia. This is a mental disorder characterized by the obsessive idea that some aspect of our appearance is severely flawed and therefore warrants exceptional measures to fix it or to hide it. There is like, it's so obvious how linked to diet culture this is, right?
这是一个非常隐蔽的谎言，是由饮食文化精心炮制出来的，旨在说服我们：如果我们很瘦，我们就会拥有一切想要的东西。你可能还会发现自己对食物感到焦虑，并且你的情绪会根据你那天对身体的感觉而发生变化。也许饮食文化最大的症状之一以及它对我们的行为和信仰产生的影响，就是身体变形恐惧症。这是一种心理障碍，其特征是对以下观点的痴迷：我们的外表某一方面存在严重缺陷，因此需要采取非同寻常的措施来修复它或隐藏它。这简直……这太明显了，它与饮食文化的联系是多么紧密，对吧？
Diet culture continuously tells us, look a certain way or you're not good enough. And that can become an obsessive thought to the point where we are so obsessed with some particular characteristic or feature of our body that we're not able to function. I used to have this when I was like 17 and 18 and I used to have this obsessive fixation with the fact that my arms, like this random feature of my body didn't look the way that people in magazines or on TV shows looked. And I would obsess over it. I would obsess over it. I would take all of these efforts to not wear singlets or to make them seem smaller or to
饮食文化不断地告诉我们，必须长成某个样子，否则你就不够好。这种想法会演变成一种强迫性的念头，让我们对身体的某个特定特征或部位着迷到无法正常生活的地步。我大约17、18岁时也曾有过这种情况，当时我对自己的手臂有一种强迫性的执念，觉得我的手臂——这个身体上随随机便的部位——长得跟杂志或电视节目里的人不一样。我会为此痴迷。我会为此反复纠结。我会想尽一切办法不穿背心，或者让手臂看起来细一点，或者
not wear particular things. And now I look back at those photos and I'm stunned because they are literally just like normal arms for a teenager to have. But that body dysmorphia kind of tricks you into thinking. otherwise. I just want to say and to note that if you have felt these things, you shouldn't in any way feel bad about yourself. These are all symptoms of diet culture and the impacts start really early. So it's often ingrained in our ways of thinking before we're even aware of it, before we're even aware of it consciously, that we are appraising our bodies in a way that coverts thinness.
不穿某些特定的衣服。现在我回看那些照片时感到十分震惊，因为它们看起来真的只是十几岁青少年再正常不过的手臂了。但那种身体畸形恐惧症会在某种程度上欺骗你的大脑，让你产生不切实际的想法。我只想说并提醒大家，如果你曾有过这种感受，绝不应该因此感到难过。这些都是饮食文化的症状，而且这种影响从很小的时候就开始了。所以，这种思维方式往往在我们甚至还没有意识到之前，甚至在我们的意识尚未察觉之前就已经根深蒂固了——我们开始以一种推崇纤瘦的方式来评估自己的身体，
and certain beauty standards, particularly above our emotional and mental well-being. Often the reason we find these beliefs so hard to shake in adulthood is because they begin in early learning in childhood and become indoctrinated into our everyday thinking. I'm sure for many of us, we maybe grew up hearing from our parents, particularly our mothers, some fairly negative statements about body image and the value of appearance. Maybe there were comments from our parents or close family members on our own bodies or on their own bodies about how they looked, how they looked ugly or fat that day. Maybe it was the prevalence of low fat and sugar-free foods in your household, comments on
并且把某些审美标准置于我们的情感和心理健康之上。通常，我们在成年后发现这些信念如此难以动摇，是因为它们始于童年时期的早期学习，并被灌输到了我们的日常思维中。我相信对于我们许多人来说，在成长过程中可能听父母，尤其是母亲说过一些相当负面关于身体形象和外表价值的言论。也许父母或亲密的家庭成员曾对我们自己的身体或他们自己的外表评头论足，比如他们那天觉得自己看起来有多丑或多胖。也许是因为你家里到处都是低脂和无糖食品，
people in the media from our parents and family and people we trusted or the restrictions of food deemed as bad. I think we all kind of know the archetype of like the almond mom, right? such like a TikTok trend at the moment, these moms or parents who had an obsession with healthy eating. And in turn, they put that on to us as their children, giving unhealthy and unsolicited comments on our body and promoting a healthy diet that is really just restrictive eating. As children, if we hear these things, if we hear our parents making comments about their own bodies, about their own appearances, we internalize it, we mimic it and we incorporate it
父母、家人以及我们信任的人对媒体上的人评头论足，或者对被视为不好的食物进行限制。我想我们大概都知道“杏仁妈妈”这种典型代表吧？这目前在TikTok上是个非常火的趋势，这些妈妈或家长对健康饮食有着近乎痴迷的执着。反过来，她们把这种执念强加给我们这些孩子，对我们的身体发表不健康且未经请求的评论，并宣扬一种实际上只是过度限制饮食的所谓健康饮食。作为孩子，如果我们听到这些话，如果我们听到父母对他们自己的身体和外表发表评论，我们就会内化这些言论，模仿它们，并将其融入
into our own beliefs and thought patterns and behaviors at such a formative and young age until it becomes so difficult to step away from and so difficult to shake. The one problematic behavior, oh my gosh, this behavior, this like practice, this really grinds my gears is the restrictions of certain foods when we're children for the purpose of weight loss or meeting beauty standards. When parents restrict the foods their children eat on a regular basis or label certain foods as off limits or as bad, often what occurs is a disordered way of seeing these foods. Children, you know, almost worship them. They see them as something that's off limits and as such something that must be really valuable if they can't
我们自己在这样一个具有塑造性的幼年时期的信念、思维模式和行为中，直到它变得如此难以摆脱、如此难以动摇。有一种有问题的行为，天哪，这种行为、这种做法，真的让我抓狂，那就是为了减肥或迎合审美标准而在我们还是孩子时限制某些食物。当父母经常限制孩子吃某些食物，或者给某些食物贴上“禁忌”或“不好”的标签时，通常会出现的情况是一种对这些食物的失调认知。孩子们，你知道的，几乎对它们顶礼膜拜。他们把这些食物视为禁忌，因此认为如果不能
have it all the time. And when they're given the freedom to do so, often they overeat when these foods become available and they become obsessed with foods that are forbidden or secret or, you know, engage in secret eating. The food begins to control us because we've never been able to have a healthy relationship with it because we've always been told it's bad or it's been restricted or it's something that's off limits. And as soon as we get that independence and that freedom, we don't know how to establish boundaries or eat the foods that we think are good for us or eat the way that we want to eat because this kind of object, this food, has this psychological control over us. It's seen as something valuable. The other insidious way that diet culture hits close to home in childhood
一直吃到它们，它们一定极其珍贵。当他们获得自由去吃这些食物时，往往会在这些食物出现时暴饮暴食，并且变得对那些被禁止的、隐秘的食物极度痴迷，或者，你知道的，进行秘密进食。食物开始控制我们，因为我们从未能与它建立健康的饮食关系，我们总是被告知它是坏的、它是被限制的或是某种禁忌。而一旦我们获得了独立和自由，我们却不知道该如何设定界限，不知道该如何去吃那些我们认为对自己有益的食物，也不知道该如何按照自己想要的方式去饮食，因为这种对象——食物，对我们具有了心理控制力。它被视为一种有价值的东西。饮食文化在童年时期潜入我们生活中的另一种隐蔽方式，
is through uneducated, inconsistent and dangerous teachings on healthy lifestyles and diets. when we're younger, diet culture can expose us to so many negative habits about food from a really young age, and it's usually with the intention of teaching children about healthy habits and about nutrition. Whilst learning about diets and food restriction is typically with the intention to educate people around healthy habits, I'm sure we all had some kind of exposure to this as children where we were told to eat, you know, five serves of veggies and two serves of fruit and, like, not eat sweets and be low on carbs and exercise like, you know, five times a week. Yes, those are like important lifestyle tips, right?
是通过对健康生活方式和饮食的、未经教育的、前后矛盾且危险的教导。当我们年幼时，饮食文化会在很小的时候就向我们灌输许多关于食物的消极习惯，这通常是以教导孩子健康习惯和营养知识为初衷的。虽然了解饮食和食物限制的初衷通常是教育人们建立健康的习惯，但我相信我们在童年时期都曾接触过类似的事情，当时我们被告知要吃，你知道的，五份蔬菜和两份水果，不能吃甜食，少吃碳水化合物，还要像，你知道的，一周锻炼五次。是的，这些都是很重要的生活方式建议，对吧？
We want children to be healthy. But when they're not taught in a consistent and appropriate manner, these lessons can actually become really damaging and ingrained in our brains as we get older. And it can also get to the point. where we're not actually thinking about how our body feels. We're not thinking about how we can treat our body well so that it can do the things that we want it to do. Instead, we're actually focused on what our body looks like.
我们希望孩子保持健康。但如果对它们的教导方式前后不一、不得其法，这些教训实际上就会变得极具破坏性，随着我们年龄的增长而在脑海中根深蒂固。而且它甚至会发展到这样一种地步：
We're focused on how much we weigh. I always think this. I think this all the time. I've had this discussion with my friends. The only people who should be allowed to give us diet advice or any advice on our physical appearance or how much we weigh, are people who have studied the interactions between food, exercise, hormones, genetics, our diet, all of those things. You need to have a fucking university degree. You need to have a qualification.
我们不再去思考我们的身体感受如何。我们不再去思考如何好好对待身体，以便让它去做我们想让它做的事情。相反，我们真正关注的是我们的身体看起来是什么样子的。我们关注的是自己的体重有多少。我总是这么想。我无时无刻不在这么想。我和朋友们也讨论过这个问题。唯一有资格给我们提供饮食建议、或关于外表及体重任何建议的人，应该是那些研究过食物、运动、荷尔蒙、基因、饮食之间相互作用的人——所有这些方面。你必须拥有一个大学学位。你必须具备专业资质。
Because unsolicited and uneducated advice, like that's not going to help anyone and it's only going to cause harm, especially when it's essentially thinly guised fat phobia and diet culture. if we've developed an unhealthy relationship with food, getting caught up in diet culture can become almost normal and become a go-to where we're counting calories or watching our weight as we enter into our teenage and adult years. But how does it operate outside of this sphere and into adulthood? How does diet culture maintain itself so strongly? This is the strange thing about diet culture.
因为那些未经请求且缺乏教育背景的建议，根本帮不了任何人，只会带来伤害，尤其是当它们本质上只是披着伪装的对肥胖的恐惧和饮食文化时。如果我们已经与食物建立了不健康的联系，那么陷入饮食文化就会变得近乎正常，并成为我们步入青春期和成年期后习以为常的应对方式。但是，它是如何在这一领域之外并在成年期发挥作用的呢？饮食文化是如何如此强大地维持自身的呢？这就是饮食文化诡异的地方，
I think many psychologists and researchers can't seem to figure out. And that is why does this trend or this social expectation that literally benefits no one except for big industry, how did it become so powerful and influential? This obsession with being thin, it literally doesn't benefit anyone. It doesn't benefit those who are naturally that way because the messaging is always, thinner, you could always look better, you could always be smaller. And it doesn't really benefit those who don't look that way either. So who is it benefiting? Who is upholding this kind of unhealthy and dangerous and unsustainable practice in this way of living? I really would ask you to think about
似乎许多心理学家和研究人员都无法弄明白。那就是：为什么这种除了大型产业之外对谁都没有实际好处的潮流或社会期望，会变得如此强大和具有影响力？这种对纤瘦的痴迷，实际上对任何人都没有好处。它对那些天生纤瘦的人没有好处，因为传递的信息永远是：你还可以更瘦，你总是可以看起来更好，你总是可以更小。它对那些外表不符合这种标准的人也没有好处。那么，它究竟在让谁受益？究竟是谁在以这种方式维持着这种不健康、危险且不可持续的做法和生活方式？我真的想请大家思考一下
that. Like who is benefiting from your insecurity? Who is benefiting from your behaviors and your beliefs. The diet industry is massive. It's like a $71 billion industry because like I said, it depends on generational cycles of fat phobia and body insecurity to promote it. It's betting on the fact that you don't feel good about yourself. So it wants you to continue not feeling good about yourself because it can make money off of you not feeling good about yourself. It wants us to believe the stigma that health is directly tied to a certain weight and a certain body type, and it wants us to keep buying products and paying for programs and consuming media that will keep us entrenched in those body insecurities forever for the sake of profit, which is so, so messed up.
这个问题。比如，谁在从你的不安全感中受益？谁在从你的行为和信念中受益。饮食行业规模巨大。它是一个高达710亿美元的产业，因为正如我所说，它依靠的是对肥胖的恐惧和身体不安全感的代际循环来推动自身发展。它在赌你对自己的现状感到不满意。所以它希望你继续对自己的现状感到不满意，因为它可以靠你对自己的不满意来赚钱。它希望我们相信这样一种刻板印象：健康与特定的体重和某种特定的体型直接挂钩，并且为了利益，它希望我们不断购买产品、支付课程费用并消费那些让我们永远深陷身体不安全感之中的媒体内容，这真的是太糟糕了、太扭曲了。
So we know how this works now, right? We know that through social approval, through normalization, early learning, repeated exposure in the media, that we begin to see thin being good, fat being bad, and therefore we buy into the beliefs, the behaviours that diet culture is teaching us. But what do we do about that? If we're in that stage right now, as I'm sure all of us are, it's a continuous pattern of learning, how do we push back against the negative beliefs that diet culture tries to teach us? So I'm going to outline some of the things that I have been doing recently some of the things that clinical research and psychology tells us to do.
所以我们现在知道这是怎么一回事了，对吧？我们知道，通过社会认可、正常化、早期学习、媒体的反复轰炸，我们开始认为瘦是好的，胖是坏的，因此我们全盘接受了饮食文化灌输给我们的信念和行为。但我们对此能做些什么呢？如果我们现在正处于那个阶段，正如我相信我们所有人一样，这是一个持续学习的过程，我们该如何抵制饮食文化试图灌输给我们的负面信念呢？因此，我将概述一些我最近一直在做的事情，以及临床研究和心理学告诉我们应该去做的事情。
If you're at a stage where you're like, this isn't working anymore, I don't want to feel this way about my body. I don't want to buy into this narrative. The first thing I did, I think I had a really, like, toxic and negative experience and negative attitude towards my body for such a long time. because I believe that lie that what I looked like was my worth, not the other things about me that were valuable. So I want you to list five things that make you a good person that have nothing to do what you look like. For example, you know, I'm a creative person.
如果你正处于这样一个阶段：觉得“这再也行不通了，我不想再对自己的身体有这种感觉了，我不想再买账这种叙事了”。我做的第一件事——我想我曾对自己的身体抱有一种非常、非常糟糕且消极的体验和消极态度，持续了很长一段时间，因为我相信了那个谎言：我的外表就是我的价值所在，而我身上其他有价值的东西却不算什么。所以我希望你列出五件能证明你是一个好人、且与你的外表毫无关系的事情。例如，你知道的，我是一个有创造力的人，
I treat others with kindness. I'm generous. You kind of get the gist. Five of those. I want you to list five and I don't want them to have anything to do with what you look like. Use these as your own purpose. personal affirmations that allow you to kind of ground yourself in what is important, especially when you're finding yourself caving into this expectation about needing to be thin.
我待人友善。我很慷慨。你大概懂我的意思了。列出五件这样的事。我希望你列出五件，并且它们绝不能与你的外表有任何关系。把这些当作你自己的个人肯定，让你能够专注于真正重要的事情，特别是当你发现自己快要向这种“必须变瘦”的期望妥协时。
Our body, and specifically what we look like, is the least important and least interesting thing about us. The content of your mind, of your heart, of your personality, that is what leaves a true impression. How you make other people feel, how you feel about yourself, that is so important and that's what should be valued, not what size of clothes you wear, what your thighs look like, whether you're thin enough to do X, Y, and Z. The second thing I would really advise you to do is to find healthy role models, either around you or in the media. There are so many people who promote a really sustainable and healthy outlook towards their bodies and towards their appearances. And kind of counter to that is eliminate people from your feed,
我们的身体，特别是我们的外表，是我们身上最不重要、最不有趣的事情。你的思想内涵、你的心灵、你的个性，那才是留下真正深刻印象的东西。你如何让其他人感到快乐，你如何看待自己，这才是真正重要的，这才是应该被珍视的，而不是你穿什么尺码的衣服、你的大腿长什么样、你是否足够瘦到可以做这样、那样的事情。我真心建议你做的第二件事是：寻找健康的榜样，无论是在你身边还是在媒体上。有很多人都在宣扬一种真正可持续且健康的、对待自己身体和外表的态度。与此相对的是，把那些
eliminate people from the content you absorb that make you feel bad about yourself. I did this the other day. There were people I had been following since I was like 15 years old whose bodies have for like so long since I was 15. made me feel bad about myself. And week on week, week by week, I still see those images of them. And every time I see those images, I feel bad. I feel bad about myself. That's not their fault, right?
让你对自身感到糟糕的人从你的动态中清除出去，把那些让你自我感觉糟糕的吸收内容从你的生活中剔除。我前几天就这么做了。有些人我从15岁起就一直关注着，他们的身材在这么长的时间里——从我15岁起——一直让我对自己的身体感到沮丧。周复一周，周而复始，我仍然能看到他们那些照片。每当我看到那些照片，我都感觉很糟糕。我对自己的感觉很差。这不是他们的错，对吧？
They're just living their life. But it's my choice to decide what is helpful and what is harming my self-perception. So removing that triggering content, that content that asks me to be thinner that requests me to, you know, engage in calorie counting and to exercise excessively. Removing that is going to be super helpful. I also want you to call yourself out when you find yourself engaging in negative self-talk and change the narrative. You know, if you're staring in the mirror and you're wearing something that you don't like
他们只是在过自己的生活。但选择什么对我有益、什么在损害我的自我认知，是我的权利。所以，清除那些会触发焦虑的内容，清除那些要求我变得更纤瘦、要求我（你知道的）去计算卡路里和过度锻炼的内容，将是非常有帮助的。我也希望你在发现自己陷入消极的自我对话时能够勇敢地指出并纠正自己，改变这种叙事。你知道的，如果你正盯着镜子，穿着一件你不喜欢的衣服，
and you're like, instead of being like, oh my God, I look so fat in this, just be like, oh, this outfit just like isn't for me right now. Or instead of being like at the gym and being like, wow, she's so much skinnier than me, be like, wow, isn't it amazing that my body could get me here and that my body is able to move me and is able to, you know, do the things I want it to do? Try not to engage in so much comparison, first of all, but also call yourself out when you find yourself talking to yourself negatively. I saw this the other day on the internet and it was like, when you say bad things to yourself, you're also saying those bad things to your inner child. Like, would you ever,
然后心里想：“天哪，我穿这个看起来好胖啊”，这时只需对自己说：“哦，这套衣服现在可能不太适合我。”或者，与其在健身房里想：“哇，她比我瘦太多了”，不如转念一想：“哇，我的身体能把我带到这里，我的身体能够支撑我活动，能够（你知道的）去做我想做的事情，这难道不是很神奇吗？”首先，尽量减少盲目攀比；同时，当你发现自己对自己进行负面评价时，也要勇敢地制止自己。我前几天在网上看到这样一句话：当你对自己说刻薄的话时，你其实也是在对你内心的那个内在小孩说那些刻薄的话。比如，你会不会
sit across from six year old or five year old you and be like you're fat and be like you need to lose weight you look hideous you look ugly can you imagine saying that to your youngest self or to any child you would never do that so why are you saying it to yourself now that little person is still in you that childlike wonder that childlike innocence that is still within you so don't say things to yourself that are going to to hurt that kind of inner child or going to negatively impact how you see yourself. I think the other thing to do is to stop labelling foods as good or bad. Once again, change the narrative. Try not to use language like bad foods or cheat meals.
坐在六岁或五岁的你对面，对TA说“你好胖”、“你需要减肥”、“你看起来太丑了”、“你真难看”？你能想象对年幼的自己或任何一个孩子说出这样的话吗？你永远不会这样做。那么，为什么你现在要对自己说这样的话呢？那个小小的自我依然留在你的体内，那种童真的惊叹、那种童年的纯真依然留存于你的内心，所以不要对自己说那些会伤害内心那个小孩、或会负面影响你自我认知的话。我认为另一件要做的事，就是停止给食物贴上好或坏的标签。再次强调，改变这种叙事。尽量不要使用“垃圾食品”或“欺骗餐”这样的语言。
Choose outfits and clothes that make you comfortable. And more importantly, choose people that make you comfortable. If the friends you have sit around and talk about how, you know, or they can't eat that, or are they going to get the sugar-free version, or how are they going to skip lunch because they're going to have a really big dinner? I really don't think that that's a positive impact. I know it's hard to step away from friends and family members as well who talk like that because we obviously love them. But maybe it's your responsibility to take what you've learned today and take what you've learned from many other aspects and many other shows or many other
选择让你感到舒适的衣服和穿着。更重要的是，选择那些让你感到舒适的人。如果你的朋友们坐在一起谈论，你知道的，他们不能吃那个，或者他们要不要买无糖版的，或者他们怎么因为晚上要吃大餐而打算跳过午餐？我真的认为这不会产生积极的影响。我也知道，要远离那些这样说话的朋友和家人很难，因为我们显然爱他们。但也许你的责任是把今天所学到的东西、以及从许多其他方面、许多其他节目或许多其他
learnings and not so much call out that language but to push back against it someone's like oh i'm not going to eat lunch because you know i'm going to have a big dinner be like oh i'm going to have lunch and i'm going to have dinner because my body needs food right now and my body needs fuel and i'm not going to punish it because diet culture has told me i need to look a particular way and set boundaries with those people who make you uncomfortable if you find that after being a someone, maybe it's your parents, maybe it's your friends, that you walk out of that situation and you feel bad about your body. Maybe it's time to push back against the aspects of their behaviour and their dialogue and their language that make you feel like that. Push back against
知识中学到的东西运用起来，不是去大声指责那种语言，而是去抵制它。如果有人说：“哦，我中午不吃午餐了，因为（你知道的）我晚上要吃大餐，”你可以说：“哦，我要吃午餐，我还要吃晚餐，因为我的身体现在需要食物，我的身体需要能量，我不会因为饮食文化告诉我需要长成某个特定样子而去惩罚它。”并且与那些让你感到不舒服的人划清界限。如果你发现和某个人（也许是你的父母，也许是你的朋友）相处之后，你走出那种情境时对自己的身体感到沮丧，
unsolicited comments. Reinforce your positive ideals about how you treat your body. Reenforce your positive attitudes towards food. And if you are someone who is really struggling with disordered eating. Go and see a therapist. Go and seek clinical help. It is so important that if you are struggling with your self-perception, with your self-worth, with your eating habits or your exercise habits in any form, there is so much support out there for you. And you don't have to live like this. It's a really, I think, terrible way to live your life worrying about your body and live your life caring about it that much and letting it take away from the joy and happiness and wonder that life really contains. So there will be some support numbers in the show
也许是时候去抵制他们那些让你产生这种感觉的行为、对话和语言了。去抵制那些未经请求就给出的评论。强化你对待身体的积极理念。强化你对食物的积极态度。如果你是一个正在与饮食失调症进行真正斗争的人，去寻求治疗师的帮助。去寻求临床帮助。如果你在任何形式的自我认知、自我价值感、饮食习惯或锻炼习惯上苦苦挣扎，有那么多支持在等着你，这真的非常重要。你没有必要这样生活。我认为，整天为自己的身体焦虑、对它过度在意，并让它夺走生活本该包含的欢乐、幸福和惊奇，这真是一种糟糕的生活方式。因此，如果在你觉得可能需要帮助的时候，节目简介中会有一些支持热线电话，
description if you're at that point where you think you might need some help. And I also just want to thank you guys for listening. Like this is a hard topic to talk about. I'm sure for many of us it's hard to listen to to understand how our body and our attitudes and beliefs has been manipulated by what is a massive industry that is benefiting from our insecurity. So thank you for walking through this with me. It was such an important episode, I think, for me to do. I learnt so much. I was able to process so much. And I'm really going to take this forward, I think, into my conversations with my friends. I hope you do as well. Start that conversation. Recognise how diet culture is insidiously working its way into your daily practices.
我也想感谢大家的收听。这是一个很难讨论的话题，我相信对我们许多人来说，也很难去聆听和理解我们的身体、态度和信念是如何被一个庞大的行业所操纵的，而这个行业正靠我们的不安全感牟利。所以，谢谢你们陪我走过这一程。我认为制作这一集对我来说非常重要。我学到了很多。我消化吸收了很多。我想我真的会把这些带入到我与朋友们的对话中。希望你们也是。开启那场对话吧。认识到饮食文化是如何潜移默化地渗透到你的日常习惯中，
and your beliefs about yourself and actively push back against that. Once again, your body is the least interesting thing about you. You contain so much more than just your physical attributes, your creativity, your love, your generosity, your intelligence. That is incredible. That is incredible. Those are the things about you that matter more than anything else. And thank you for listening.
以及你对自己的信念中，并积极地去抵制它。再说一次，你的身体是你身上最不有趣的事情。你所拥有的远不止你的外在特质，你的创造力、你的爱、你的慷慨、你的智慧，这些都是不可思议的。这太不可思议了。这些才是你身上最重要、高于一切的品质。谢谢你们的收听。
Thank you for listening to this episode. If you enjoyed it, if you learned something, please feel free to give it a five-star review on Spotify, Apple Podcasts, wherever you listen. Follow the show on Instagram. It's at That Psychology Podcast. Every week I do a poll and let you decide one of my episodes. So if there is something you really want to hear, reach out. I'll probably do it. I love getting some inspiration.
谢谢收听本期节目。如果你喜欢它，如果你学到了什么，请随时在Spotify、Apple Podcasts或你收听节目的任何平台上给它一个五星好评。关注本节目的Instagram账号，是 That Psychology Podcast。每周我都会做一个投票，让你们决定我其中一期节目的主题。所以如果你有什么特别想听的内容，请联系我。我大概率会去做的。我喜欢获取一些灵感。
And thank you again for listening. I hope you have an amazing week. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
再次感谢你们的收听。希望你们能度过棒极的一周。2%。这是当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、体能和建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's TWO.% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. On the Look Back at it podcast For 1979, that was a big moment for me 84 was big to me I'm Sam J And I'm Alex English Each episode, we pick a year
请在IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《2%》。名字是数字2和一个百分号。在《Look Back at it》播客中，对于1979年，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻，84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J，我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，
unpack what went down And try to make sense of how we survived it With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s 84 was a wild year I don't think there's a more important year For black people
剖析当时发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何在朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家的陪伴下幸存下来的，比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to Look Back at it On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts Or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not
请在IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听《Learn the Hardway》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯。这个空间聚焦于黑人男性的经历，进行坦诚的对话，而这些对话在其他任何地方其实都不安全，但你是在和一个懂行的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人随身带着一套盔甲？它向世界释放出一种信号：你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不
mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives
意味着你需要这么做。请在IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Learn the Hardway》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你在这个特定的测试上造假了两次，对吗？我只在测试上造了一次假。这需要一大批互联网侦探
to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian. Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安。迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的大脑都要炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《爱之陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。请在IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《爱之陷阱》播客。这是一档IHeart播客。百分之百真人保证。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。